مرور شهر على هجوم حماس المميت
على إسرائيل وزعم القوات البرية الإسرائيلية أنها
حاصرت مدينة غزة التي
تعتبر وفقًا للجيش الإسرائيلي قاعدة رئيسية
لحماس وبنيتها التحتية الإرهابية،
بينما يبدو أن الصراع في غزة
سيتصاعد بمجرد انتهاء الحرب.
بنيامين نتنياهو يقول إن إسرائيل
ستحتفظ بمسؤوليتها عن
أمن غزة لفترة غير محددة
نتنياهو أدلى بهذه
التصريحات خلال مقابلة مع قناة ABC
News أول تصريحاته العلنية حول
مستقبل غزة أه بمجرد انتهاء هذه الحرب
وحتى ذلك الحين أكد أنه سيكون هناك
لا يوجد وقف إطلاق نار مع أنصار الشريعة حتى
تطلق الجماعة المسلحة سراح جميع الرهائن،
ووفقًا لوزارة
الصحة الفلسطينية في الضفة الغربية، فقد قُتل أكثر من 10000
شخص في غزة خلال
الهجوم الإسرائيلي الذي استمر شهرًا،
وقال مسؤول رفيع المستوى في الأمم المتحدة إن هذا العدد يتحدى
الإنسانية، تعيش الآن في القاهرة  والدكتور
ريتشارد برينان، مدير الطوارئ الإقليمي
لمنظمة الصحة العالمية، الدكتور برينان يرحب بعودتك،
شكرًا لوجودك
معنا، شكرًا لك، فيما يتعلق
بالبنية التحتية العامة للمجتمع المدني،
الخدمات الأساسية، ما هو موجود وما لا
يعمل في
غزة جيدًا أه كل شيء أه كان  تضررت
تعطلت أه في الجانب الصحي
كما ذكرت أه أكثر من 10000 حالة وفاة
ثلثاها تقريبا بين
النساء والأطفال 25000 إصابة مرة أخرى
في الجانب الصحي الآن لدينا 39% من
المستشفيات متوقفة عن العمل
والباقي 60 بالمئة فردية
تعمل جزئيًا فقط أه لدينا حوالي
ثلثي العيادات أه
معطلة بالطبع المدارس لا
تعمل على الإطلاق الأطفال
تعطل تعليمهم لأنهم
يستضيفون أكثر من 700 ألف
نازح داخليًا في
ظروف غير صحية وغير مزدحمة بشكل صادم أه  لقد
سمعت عن مشاكل
إمدادات المياه ومحطة تحلية المياه،
أه تعتمد بشكل متزايد على
المياه المعبأة التي يتم جلبها عبر الحدود،
ومجرد تمزق كامل
للنسيج الاجتماعي، كما تعلم، أه عائلة لدينا
جميعًا أه زملاء وأصدقاء  الذين أه
يعيشون ويعملون في أه في فلسطين وفي
غزة وتدمير
منازلهم أه سبل عيشهم على
نطاق واسع وفقا لأحد التقديرات أم
المساعدات الإنسانية التي
تصل فعلا إلى غزة قد وصل التدفق اليومي الحالي
للمساعدات في أحسن الأحوال  قمم متفرقة بنسبة
7٪ من مستوى ما قبل الحرب قد يكون
متوسطها أقل من 4٪،
أسقط سلاح الجو الأردني
إمدادات طبية مليون أه إنا خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع هو أن
الخيار هنا هو أن هناك شيئًا
يمكن أن تفعله دول أخرى
بجدية بالتزامن و
مع الإسرائيليين بإذن من
إسرائيل ولكن هل هذا شيء يمكن
تنفيذه بجدية من قبل
الآخرين بشكل جيد؟ لا أعتقد أن هذا
خيار مستدام، أعني أنه من
الواضح جدًا ما يتعين علينا القيام به، نحتاج إلى تحرير الأشياء
الأكثر قسوة التي نحتاجها  للحصول على
البنية التحتية اللوجستية في شمال
سيناء هنا في مصر أه توسيعها عندما نحتاج إلى
عملية تحقق أفضل وأكثر سلاسة وكفاءة أه على
الحدود التي يديرها
الإسرائيليون حاليًا ثم على الجانب الآخر
من الحدود داخل غزة  نحن بحاجة إلى
التوزيع المحمي للمساعدات دون عوائق، يمكننا أن نعرف أن
لدينا القدرة على زيادة حجم المساعدات
بشكل كبير أه كما أشرت من قبل
أه هذا التصعيد الأخير
يقدر أنه كان هناك 500 شاحنة تجلب
مساعدات البضائع التجارية إلى غزة كل يوم
منذ ذلك الحين  في بداية الصراع
كان لدينا حوالي 420 شخصًا في المجمل، يمكننا أن نفعل ما هو
أفضل بكثير إذا حصلنا على مساحة للتحرك